how would you recruit me to your state
as a governor
good question great question yeah well
the first thing that we need
is businesses staying we've lost
coinbase we've got a tesla gigafactory
going to florida
businesses are leaving in droves their
headquarters are moving out
hewlett-packard moved out
they're endless where did uh where did
that php start
no california where did they go to
texas and florida well you know i
interviewed for example an hvac uh one
of my hvac sales person and he's saying
he's losing
his employees that's not the question to
other states prince
yeah well so the answer is how do you
get businesses to stay
first of all you get businesses to stay
with proper
reasonable regulation not this
overbearing regulation that we have now
we need to lower income taxes for
everyone that's
very key no income taxes under the first
250 000
is a pay raise for everyone in
california can you do that it has to be
done with the legislature okay
yeah so that's by the way you do that
that's a that's a very big thing if
you're but
that makes california competitive of
course it does exactly because right now
we're not
how do you pass that with the massive
budget that you have for the state
all these social programs you want to
cut taxes for people under a quarter of
a million
oh yeah that's rough because here's why
most of the taxes
somewhere around well the vast majority
of our taxes
are paid by people making over two
hundred fifty thousand dollars that's
where the vast majority of our taxes
come from
you actually know the number uh it's so
right now if we had
uh if if we instituted my plan and we
had
no taxes on the first 250 thousand
dollars
we would generate uh rough a little over
60 percent of our revenue from the
people over 250 000
under the current tax regime but here's
what we need when we legalize gambling
when we have toll roads when we reduce
welfare costs when we reduce community
college and high school costs
by combining community colleges and high
schools into
future schools what are you doing you're
going through every layer of government
you're getting folks off of social
services by giving them more
income you're creating more
opportunities to spend you're building
more houses which is more tax revenue
you are growing the economy to where
over time
you do not need as many tax revenues one
of the most reasonable democrats that
i've heard in a long time
outside of the whole occupy my state i
want to own thing
it's really very reasonable thank you
all right i don't know
what your opposition is to stopping
people dying on our street hey are there
gonna be any debates
i hope so you know right now guess who
controls the election date
the governor's office
if any state ever did need a state of
emergency if any state ever did it
california
do you hear about the laws how do you
feel how do you feel about caitlyn
jenner running
with her policies any republican running
is not going to make anything happen in
the state first of all you go through
the policies of the other candidates
nobody has a plan nobody has a plan that
i found
i they're they're generic things can you
pull up caitlyn jenner's plan
less red tape or okay maybe we should
deal with the homelessness because the
person outside the airport hangar is
is is homeless says caitlyn jenner where
where's the real plan
we need real action now i don't really
care about the other candidates
because i don't believe they're my
competition my competition is governor
newsome right
who is screwing this statement i think i
don't think he is because i think
he's i think people have accepted the
fact that this is not a good governor
for the state of california
i think people have finally got to a
point where they're
so that's what i'm saying i don't think
he's your competition i think i think
the state of california is i think your
competition is
john cox it's eastern partner it's
jenner it's doug oh you know you got a
few of these guys
obviously major williams some of these
other guys that are coming up that are
you know potentially making a little
name for themselves but
that's really the people you're looking
at i i don't believe it uh it it
like i remember you thank you you think
newsome 100
if newsom gets recalled we win newsome's
gotta go
that's that is we need people to say yes
on the right now gets recalled you win
that's right so you're saying if the x
amount of votes for the recall
on the election i'm sorry the recall
election is happening it's 100
it's happening but the date hasn't been
set because the governor's office gets
to determine that
meanwhile they're suing their own
administration for a law that they
signed into law
calling their own laws on sunday on july
4th yeah it's
six o'clock at night it's ridiculous
it's ridiculous
and buses will be provided for all his
supporters
have you had have you had any debates
yet has there been any debates with
anybody else no zero debates
i will debate any of that you know and
this got you ready man this is a good
little prep
you guys are easy bring it on i don't
know if the audience is saying that but
it's good for you to know
that's good we can do patrick's got a
whole production house
here we can we can get a we can get an
animated gavin newsom and an animated
caitlyn jenner we can have the whole
debate right here so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye